o lado pessoal de quem fala a rodar que
sejam muito bem vindos os canais 1
milhão eo e vejam só que eu comprei olha
aí o pessoal quanto o visto de uma loja
eo eu comprei imóvel e indiretamente
porque faz não só a capa olha aí a
primeira coisa que vocês venham tubarão
cheio de dentro foi nervoso bem e se não
veja só o título deste livro constrói um
tubarão é só isso complementou para o pé
mas constroem um branco um livro como
assim eu quero ver o que isto é e eu
continuarei a tiro livre informação o
maquete com 48 centímetros de
comprimento por aí eu vou construir um
tubarão a partir de um livro com 48
centímetros de altura ou o comprimento
da igreja vai ficar todo 51 dura assim
como assim e ainda diz outra coisa de
censura e sem cola é apenas capaz de
construir
eu saí eu cheguei aqui mesmo e hoje
comenta o que vocês acham que tem sérgio
vai dar certo ou não seja nem vai dar
certo comenta em tubarão se acharem
farelado comentem tipo sei lá mas ele
não sei como é que vocês quiserem se
inserem vai dar certo' branco e já saiu
só deixei muito aqui no espírito isso
não foram inscritos em risco rebels é a
outra coisa eu já tenho mais de dez pra
fazer vídeos com tubarões por dentro vem
muita coisa boa e inscreva-se mesmo ele
para lá vieram ter comigo tem por dentro
agora junto né hoje é isso tem muita
informação aqui acerca dos barões play o
tubarão branco técnica tamil deus por aí
eu vou ler essa informação porque eu
tenho pressão quando o tubarão branco
nunca vi uma empresa coloca debaixo dela
depois lança um rápido ataque com a sua
potente cauda álbum cultural taekowndo
como assim
ao mesmo tempo que abre as mandíbulas de
tal forma que sua cabeça sido forma
assim o precedeu a gripe bem estranho e
depois foi se bruscamente causando um
impacto brutal famoso ataque do tubarão
um surfista a limitação alguma intenção
do tubarão branco é muito variável é e
costumeiro do tipo de alimento ou seja
um tubarão quando todo o tipo e humano
ou agora sim é para a construção da
estrutura um branco é o maior é o maior
dos clientes e possivelmente a
construção está parada por fases ea
primeira vai ser e é cabeção olha isso o
colégio d
olhei isso vai ficar muito loucos e eu
to muito útil para construir isso eu vou
saber que o tempo de construção a china
e índica que chove eu não sei se vou
levar uma hora construído do brasil
formar 10 minutos 20 minutos eu não sei
mas vamos construir aqui em preços iriam
ficar assim tão chato né há muitas
partes que eu vou cortar e voltar e
mostrar os pides na sociedade e assim
você poderá acompanhar melhor é que a
evolução do nosso plano é pequeno pois
logo depois um livro muito louco por ela
está a montagem só queremos entrar aqui
as pessoas
olha isso esteja a cabeça essa é para
número dois para o número 1 tem os
dentes para 1 673 mil olho isso é só o
cartão é só papel tem muita página e e
já complica
aqui começa a complicar olhes para bater
na estrutural
meu deus
segundo teodoro não passam por aí que só
se gostam ou para fazer o que tem é xeke
prozac já parece tudo a mesma coisa
ontem o fundo azul fundo azul estampado
acho que é um dos fortes esta parte aqui
ó
por isso eu acho que temporários têm
aulas têm estrelas bom estamos aqui só
chega de enrolação livrá la
só parece o começo da peça já tem roupas
todos pois é só encaixar e vai ficar um
tubarão muito louco e para lá
[Aplausos]
sua voz não só como está ficando tubarão
olha é isso jato que há muito tempo acho
que já possua uma hora eo windows só
consegui montar isto tá sic st
[Aplausos]
o irmão só depois de quatro horas aqui
tentar montar a exposição olha já tomic
a base jovem também o tubarão e
obrigatoriamente de usar cola é porque
está claro que foi muito complicado
montar porque as peças saltavam seriam
todas então usa cola os helicópteros
também e vejam só contar ficar por aí
agora é só colocar aqui um swell e estou
muito cansado
nesta classe
e agora pessoal segundo momento final do
4º batalhão em cima da nossa barra agora
lá isso não está e não entrega
isso não entra e finalmente que vai
montar o nosso era um pessoal e em 321
velho não só é isso
[Música]
mas eu só como ficou olha está muito
lindo claro que tem aqui professores
claro que não tem isso de forma perfeita
e os ecólogos e super 3 josey super cola
do título com a cola tuc muito cansado
já montado e nas costas
tudo para montar um tubarão de papel
olha é isso meu está muito louca estou
muito orgulhoso é que a européia e como
sempre quando vocês muito uma coisa que
não sabem montar a sobra peças olha isso
muita coisa que sobrou aldeias inclusive
tem peso do tubarão que eu nem sei onde
encaixam olha aí eu não sei de quem foi
essa em play
eu não sei de quem se encaixa ser um a
lugar nenhum bicho em caixa e eu
procurei muito tempo mas o resultado
final está aqui pessoal também não ficou
muito louco e minha parte tudo brita ou
essa boca e lê muito e sim isto é não
apenas um cão mas só espero que vocês
tenham destaque deste vídeo já sabe
neste ano um outro league school for
inscrito no canal e chiclete eu não sei
agora vamos fazer para descobrir neste
vídeo o ataque do tubarão para lá
[Música]